the Nintendo Entertainment System is one
of the most important game consoles of
all time
a Nintendo is bringing it back for a
whole new generation I'm Tony and this
is your classic GameSpot news update the
NES classic edition can fit in the palm
of your hand but that's not even its
most impressive feature it has 30
built-in games including classics like
Super Mario Brothers Legend of Zelda and
Metroid that's a hundred and fifty
dollar value on Nintendo's Virtual
Console we've got the full list up on
GameSpot on top of that the pac-10
controller is a spitting image for the
original NES gamepad in this version can
even connect to a Wii mote to play
Virtual Console games on the Wii and Wii
U you can even use pro controllers with
the new system the NES classic edition
hits store shelves on November 11th
it'll cost you 60 bucks which seems like
a fair price for introducing a whole new
audience to a classic console next up
for Nintendo is the NX so if you want to
keep up with everything happening there
you're already in the right place